hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
nicht lachen challenge auf meinem kanal
ihr seht schon ich bin in mein zimmer
zwar leide allerdings in ihrem zimmer
mit dabei sein kapital braucht 50
ich kann hier keine strandpromenade
bieten aber dafür kranken die baby ohne
apps aktiv
[Musik]
sandra abgewandert ist anderer im zug
immer mehr salat super trap die einfach
somit ist das irgendwie seine kinder zu
retten
also macht somit mehr nachkommen zu
vermeiden nix da friert diesmal wo ich
mein geld jetzt echtzeit
das ist 1 1 sandra hast du nicht drehen
und lukas schulz ist ja durch die boxen
durch da gibt's ja ich weiß ja genauso
als wir das erste mal die scooter mit
dir gefallen und die teile fahren 20 km
h oder so sander ist so durchgehend 3 km
h gefahren das ist aber selbst nur
soweit ich kein führerschein ab ich bin
mit einer so schnee aber du hast theorie
prüfung bestanden ja das kann ich
nein
bitte sagen sie ein sprachkommando
[Musik]
adresseingabe hamburg bitte sagen sie
ein sprachkommando brauchbare befindet
zu erwarten sind
luca das weiß sogar nicht aber die
russen sprechen kein haarhaus ja doch
das hatten wir schon mal mit svetlana
erzählt mit deiner mutter was hat die da
noch mal gesagt sagt auch wir vorne
haben ungefähr gambo deutsche sprache
schwere sprache
hamburg
sagen sie ein sprachkommandos adamo
abbruch nein vielleicht auch eltern wenn
das sind die ganze zeit abbruch versteht
für mich immer auf dem video markieren
und dann das
dieses französischem ihm aber sie hat
richtig gut nachgemacht und banana gab
ich frage mich was gucken wir uns gerade
commerce anna da bist du im nächsten
video ist wohl eine frage so mag
das ist also wirklich jeder clip ist
alles eins zu eins du du bist auch
einfach jede person von denen die wir
bisher gesehen haben uns ja an eine frau
nice nice
du fühlst dem ich für den ich für seine
sprache was war deine lieblings line
alles alles der künste kriegst du kannst
du was ich gerade an ein und meine hier
meine jacke dazu diese passen sagt lasst
uns einmal weiter gucken mit dem
es umfasst dünner
das hier ist red bull red bulls die
wahlsendung und gelegt wie auf meinen
nackten dekanaten bedroht da wird nicht
kleiner bruder ja gerade bei dünner mit
meinem bruder red bull stimmte ich
müssten eigentlich war glocken dafür
übels peinlich egal soll er machen junge
hat wird erst mal gönnen mag es leute
und danach leute vorsichtig und alter
wir haben uns der zunge zeitung
letztlich egal ob seiner das ist neuer
tiefpunkt was dabei sein was mich dass
gerade erinnert wieder an dich man habe
ihn während uhr in der cl kommt um mit
meiner maschine am 1
das amg sandra ich war so schnell dass
mich mein tipp aus meiner klasse
gefeiert
[Gelächter]
ja geil geil ich keine stars ließ brüllt
saß ja kenne ich nicht ob ich zock so
irgendein handy spielen nur ins tal
was hab kein bild kein parade ich kann
nicht kommen kann oder soll ich noch
drei mal sagen noch hier sagen 1 1
sandra wieder das wieder 11 der nächste
klippe ist vom wendler ich kurz ins grab
da ist dein wagen warum machst du das
richtig sie ihre liebe hat eigentlich
das komplette video gesehen vom wendler
bisschen so der verfliegt halt in jeder
sekunde gefühlten alter aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ey werden freut wie
so ein dickes auto schenken
ich würde auch direkt mich ausziehen
dann schnell bett und ein auto und eine
brezel noch das andere der mündlichen
prüfungen mit bauklötzen spielen
ich bin mit bauklötzen nicht bei
fortnight
[Musik]
mein zuhause dort auch mal so ganz
komische schritte wenn ihr denn sie geht
so nach vorher zurück zeigt meine in der
kamera was für schritte macht gezeigt
ja ich kaufe jetzt nicht reden aber ich
hab's mir nachher schlittern ja
wundervoll getanzt freund wird jetzt
dreimal die latte zu schießen will
schafft dann müsst ihr nicht an dass ein
erster versuch ja wahrscheinlich jesus
mich geschnitten es weiter versucht
weiter weil so wia klar
der war auch tritt die dritte versuchen
wenn er trifft ein bisschen leicht an
kraft trifft er wohl wer weiß
krass alter müssen die leute jetzt
wurden like und haben video da lassen an
der stelle ich das heute wieder deutlich
zu beenden meine lieben freunde hier
sandra und ich haben uns mal wieder eine
nicht lachen challenge compilation
angeschaut diesmal allerdings nicht
zusammen bei mir in köln sondern sandra
bielefeld ich in köln weil leute stay
home bleibt zu hause bleibt gesund und
sandra hat die letzten sechs wörter ich
bin die geilste aus deutschland
[Musik]